it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes Oh what in the world welcome to
the movie by hashtagging movie fights
live it's not live wrong tape so what
are we doing just hashtag movie fights
yeah hashtag movie fights there you go
and I gotta give a shout-out to the
Ga'Hoole iggins in Ala Nation hoot hoot
Percival is in the house we've got an
all-star Throwdown today
we are not joking around on that we're
gonna be we're gonna be talking about
the new movie the jokester
first off let's meet our friends he is a
real reject and a delightful young man
welcome back to the party Greg Alba
exciting to be here man I rode with Edie
here and so I'm hoping Jurina wins that
way it's not awkward on the way back did
give you a ride or did you give that a
ride I gave at a ride okay so if he wins
I'm kicking it out call that someone
Hoover okay and this gentleman he's the
host of the Nerd goat podcast and he can
be seen regularly on sju Ed Greer
welcome back my friend oh thank you
thank you guys I know that well these
guys are coops now but thank you guys
for having me this is really cool
haven't done movie fights in a while and
done movie fights in a while but if I do
and I will walk up the 405 like the
Incredible Hulk
just Oh wandering into the distance
dealing with your rage thank you and and
we have from Collider live and now we
welcome over to the movie fight studio
Dorina aerilon Oh No thank you for
having me I'm very excited to actually
do an actual movie fights because I've
only done the comic-con one and that one
but this is what I'm actually nervous
for and I hope Greg is right and I do
win we'll see way you were nervous for
the comic-con well I would have been
Friday night okay much more relaxed
everybody was drunk on Cano yeah though
the comic-con funk hanging in the air
well I'm excited to throw down with you
guys and I will be hosting and judging
along with the Dan cam welcome to dance
dance square hello Dan Morelle what's
going on my friends it's my first time
in the fact checking seat for a while
yeah yeah we've had some rotating
fact-checkers it's good to have the man
with the quickest fact checking fingers
in the biz I do my best out I do my best
oh yes you do just the fact well you did
like in the head movie fights in a row
didn't you rambling then I was on the
last ones yeah I'm back over here okay
good to have you there and Danielle you
are not the voice of the people you were
just that you are the delightful voice
of the Queen herself Daniel Radford I
have the voice of myself but y'all so
what we want to do we want to make sure
that we're still keeping this I love the
people I want to continue to advocate
and be the voice of the people and so
even though if this episode and other
episodes may not be live what we would
like you to do is just like you do want
honest trailer commentaries on honest
trailers if you have something that you
want me to say or if you have like a
little tidbit or some knowledge leave
those down in the comments we're gonna
be looking at them and we're gonna be
looking for some comments or some tweets
that we can highlight on the next
episode of movie fights so still love
y'all
that sounds wonderful yeah respond to
the show
well I'll chime in all
Danielle and we'll have fun you know
what we'll pretend like it's live we can
just watch it together
corgis yes porgies owls sharks etc you
guys what do you say jte role that sick
ass package
[Music]
thanks door okay so now we're physically
fighting right oh no I don't know what
you heard this is yeah I know that that
common common shares were thrown it was
quite a con you guys okay here is
question number one all right this is a
toughy right out of the gate you'll see
what cinematic portrayal of the Joker
has been the best there's the question
there it is you can watch you can read
it as well as so we're gonna start with
the player number one Greg oh yeah
well my pick is Keith ledger crowns a
chair over my pick is Heath Ledger yeah
I think all our picks are pretty good
picks but for me this is the one that
truly rings as soul no this is closest
to my heart he's a true agent of chaos
he's menacing sadistic yet he's also
funny
nearly every line he said in that movie
became an instant quote and to me he's
the closest you know interpretation of
the comics version of the Joker that
truly actually felt realistic and
tangible and he's also a criminal
mastermind who knows how to expose the
darkness and people when fear is
thrusted into their face he's a master
manipulator who can like spew out these
twisted philosophies and yet as an
audience member you can still watch and
ago I can actually kind of see where
he's going with this I can actually see
where he's coming from
and being in the shoes of the he's the
villain of it yet he's the one who
steals to show the whole time and he's
not the protagonist as someone's pick
will be here though and it's the way
that Joker was always meant to be viewed
and in terms of showcasing the true
opposite end of the same coin in
reference to Batman he truly does it the
best between I think all these picks
that are coming up all right going with
Heath Ledger Dark Knight thank you Greg
Eady
well I am going with yoking Phoenix as
the Joker and and this new fact check
the pronunciation please joke there
Joaquin it's like and actually it's
pronounced like so the Yoker is one of
my really the Joker is to me it's one of
these things where you have your
different interpretations but one of the
things you always come back to is the
actual madness and I think that this
movie is the best at actually portraying
the madness and have the madness
intensifies and some of the reasons for
the madness and I think that's what it's
trying to do it's also maintaining a
little bit of mystery even though it's
telling somewhat of an origin story so I
think with all those elements involved
and I'll elaborate more as we get more
into it but like with all those elements
the the mystery the the mystery as well
as explanation the great performance by
Joaquin Phoenix and all these things
boiled it down into one of the
quintessential Joker's and the best one
to me
right on Thank You Edie dureena so both
of your picks are excellent I love both
Joker's but my personal favorite and I
think the Joker that crap that actually
captures the true essence of the Joker
that we all know from comics and also TV
show movies is mr. mark hamill legend
the best Joker laughs that's ever
existed in my opinion the he's
definitely out of all the Joker's that
we've had he's the yin and yang to
Batman when it comes to you know good
versus evil as well as both of them
coming from representing you know Gotham
creating an evil person and a good
person that's trying to you know that
and they're both fighting each other all
the time and I also think it's it's one
of those things where Batman can't kill
him right at least specifically in mask
of the phantasm and the most of Mark
Hamill's portrayal is a joker Batman
just can't bring himself to kill him
because he understands that and that
right there is a win for for this
character
additionally he's a psychopath like out
of all the Joker's we've seen he's
actually a legit psychopath he's a
narcissist who manipulates people who is
an evil mastermind and on top of that he
charms his way into you he manipulates
people by being funny and that's what
makes him to me the most scary hmm all
right fight it out you guys go there's
gonna be a lot of here because of course
they're gonna share some similar
qualities like I I personally find Heath
Ledger's to be the best manipulator of
them all I mean the heat he flat out you
know kills Rachel in the movie and still
manages to put Harvey Dent on the path
that he wants him to go on when Harvey
Dent has an opportunity to just kill him
and the thing with Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker
to me it's essential that Joker is a
criminal mastermind to me that's a big
integral part to his character I think
Mark Hamill's has it I don't feel like I
feel like walking Phoenix's character is
he I love the portrayal I love I love
that movie but at the same time it
doesn't truly evolved into Joker for me
personally like he every one of his
kills is is personal
whereas Heath Ledger's is more
reminiscent of Joker's someone who can
kill that random kill intentionally kill
with purpose not kill with purpose and
it's like this cult leadership that he
sort of forms by the end of the movie is
by happenstance it's it's by chance when
it's not intentional at all in the mad
you are about that I am I'm quite sure
you think those are deadly barbs but
that's the thing about the Joker to me
and this is all a big opinion contest
fights what that made the case and in my
opinion it is more about the evils of
Gotham that create the Joker and the
Joker creating Batman I do understand
that there's a common you know oh he
dropped him in the juice and he came out
all weird and there's all sort of
different origins people have or
motivations for him but I just think
that the best depiction of the Joker to
me is a manifestation of Gotham's very
madness and that is what I got in this
movie your guy could have been a weird
paramilitary guy who kind of washed out
of a weird militia and kind of put on
some grease paint and did some stuff
hers is very very jocular and and and
dangerous but only as dangerous as a
cartoon guy can be whereas mine is true
actual Travis Bickel Ian madness and his
has his henchmen by happenstance I agree
with that however it's the only way that
I would ever see him being able to feel
the gang if they felt like they were
part of a cultural movement whereas
there he's not part of none of his
henchmen and either of these things are
part of any sort of cultural movement
and have no real reason to be there in
that danger all the time
well Gotham is so instilled with
corruption and gangsters and stuff and
to me there's 100 gangs you could join
where you don't get a hammer dropped on
your head all the time well to add to
both your points but also mess with your
guys's points I'm gonna kill you right
now Joker is the intellectual Joker
right like he's a philosopher he's
highly emotionally intelligent that
bathroom scene with Batman is you know
amazing but he the bathroom remember
when they went to pee in the air
but I think that he he knows because
he's so smart I think he knows that
Batman himself is uncorruptible right
and so that's why hands up corrupting
Harvey Dent right and to show Batman I
can do this to other people maybe not
you so because of that like that I think
I think he Ledger's Joker is smart
enough to know that he can't beat Batman
specifically he can create chaos in the
city but but Batman's never gonna be
like what he's what he wants him to me
that make sense but that's part of the
joy in the in the in the chaos of
messing with Batman like in that
interrogation scene when Joker is being
beat up he's still winning in the
interrogation even though he's basically
getting harm he's still winning
ultimately because he knows that cross a
line but he also knows unlike other
Joker specifically won't gain phoenixes
Joker he does I feel he Ledger Joker
knew right from wrong right and he chose
to to act in the wrong way because he
was trying to he's anti-establishment
right and where is he where is Joaquin
he's a little scarier to me because you
don't know what he's gonna do it like he
he doesn't seem to know what's right or
wrong or he chooses to just completely
go crazy so that's where to me Joaquin
is actually scarier than he ledger but
we only see that Joaquin actually
turning into the Joker the last 30
minutes of the of the movie right
we don't really see we this is more of a
the Batman Begins version of Joker but
also a to that point though I would like
to say that I think that is the power of
this particular portrayal is is because
it's basically saying that these are the
type of falling down several days sort
of situations giving off your meds the
city's overrun garbage super rats you
know there's just so many things
happening everybody's reading newspapers
you know there's some kind of outbreak
there's so many things going to make
your mom yeah oh yeah your mom's a
weirdo who's obsessed with basically
Trump you know I mean that's there's a
lot of things that are in that movie
that that would break your mind and I
think that it's kind of showing that it
isn't just a couple smears of grease
paint it isn't just know
it's not that it's like real society
chipping away at somebody to the point
where they are the beginnings of a Kaos
agent which is what Joaquin is at the
end of the movie and I just think that
that person could theoretically develop
into the sort of Joker's you guys are
talking about or positive world where
that this weird Joker fish guy can't
exist but that is go ahead and respond
and then roll that into your final I
mean to me that is just pure theoretical
though because there's nothing about him
that seems clever and scheming or
anything like that where he does evolve
into the actual Joker like as the meme
says to you you are definitely obsessed
with hmm check my plots and plans and
pots and pans and I am just like this
person is unpredictable monstrous will
stab true that's the Joker he is all but
all of our Joker's are unpredictable and
crazy I don't think he's scarier because
everyone he kills in that movie is just
pure intent it's like these are people
who have wronged him personally or he
feels wronged personally whereas like
the guy made the pencil joke at the
beginning that's kind of just a random
kill he gets upset at Michael Jai White
in the film
let's go into final thought yeah great
so yeah I mean I just feel like that
character of Arthur Fleck is a cool
slice of Travis Bickle and Rupert Pupkin
put together right like that's who he is
but he doesn't feel like the Joker comic
to me to me Joker should be a character
that is yes menacing unstable but also
clever conniving master criminal of
sorts someone who's a great at scheming
and stuff Arthur never really evolves
into the Joker for me in that film like
and to me there's really I can't say
there's a mystery to the character when
the whole thing is focused on him the
whole time and it's it's the pure
dissection of that guy and with Mark
Hamill's portrayal of the Joker you're
going off with a mask of the phantasm
right in that I see I think to really
appreciate Mark Hamill's Joker it
requires the viewing experience of
watching the TV show really getting
absorbed in the medium I think just
going off of Mark Hamill's Joker in
Batman mask of the phantasm he's not mm
like he's
important in it but he's really a B
story to it and I'd I feel like with
there's been better portrayal of Mark
Hamill as the Joker explored in the
animated series explored in The Killing
Joke even like I don't like the first
three minutes in that movie but I think
it's better there where you really do
get to see it because in the mask of the
phantasm it's kind of more on the
OneNote side it's more caricature
aspects for me and also to say like Mark
Hamill's is the best I feel like there's
a lot with acting that involves body
language facial expressions that really
gets thrown to the animators there as
opposed to Mark Hamill actually doing it
with Ledger I feel like you get the best
of both worlds you have this unhinged
psychopath who wants nothing but to
bring you know pure chaos to Gotham
bringing out that chaos and Gotham yeah
he's funny as well and I got it I think
that's some kind of an integral part
he's got to be a little bit funny to be
the Joker were Arthur reflect never
really made me laugh and you you get to
watch all these things take place of how
clever this guy is he is the most
intellectual one but he is still also
just as unhinged as the rest because of
how crazy he is he's able to get away
with these super elaborate schemes like
with having like kidnapping the the two
boats and having them choose with each
other was just a gnarly experience and
able to manipulate Harvey Dent is so
clever because he knows he can't change
Batman so he's going to change Harvey
Dent instead so even in the end when
he's captured he still wins essentially
in that movie he's still the winner in
that film he's chaotic yet focused
terrifying yet fascinating and you feel
like you understand him yet he's so
mysterious and and also the thing with
and last thing I'll say the thing that I
feel is most comics accurate with him is
his multiple choice background because
that is so integral with The Killing
Joke as well the head that he there's a
line in there down or through there by
having a multiple choice background and
when he tells those stories you're kind
of like there must be some truth to
those scars somehow to be that psychotic
to carve your own smile in your face
that to me is truly scary thank you Greg
and well again it's all in one's opinion
of the Joker and these are vastly
different worlds they're trying to do
vastly different things so it's kind of
hard to compare but just for my dollar
for my good
American dollar I want a joker that is
his motive even though he of his pills
were technically personal they were also
psychotically motivated there were there
wasn't any just straight aid to be you
can't really act like you're safe in
Gotham and think that you're not
offending the Joker somehow you know a
guy with a television show offended Emma
people down at the post office
Thomas Wayne so many people that aren't
related to him offended him and were in
danger so he is a dangerous individual
this is about a more realistic depiction
of actual psychotic behavior I'm sorry
real psychotics don't kick it with a
bunch of gangsters do pencil tricks and
all this jazz they stab people in necked
in their apartments and they let other
people go because they like them that's
what real psychotics do so it's just a
matter of taste and my personal opinion
and in my personal opinion the Joker the
Joker doesn't make sense as an adversary
to Batman on a bunch of levels neither
of nobodies Joker at this table in a
phone booth of Batman would stand a
chance so it's really more about how the
fear he can he can instill in the city
and an allegiance he can instill in his
henchmen and the only feared only Joker
that made real fear in the city real
change in the city and inspired enough
people in the city to have an actual
army of goons that would fight this
capable martial arts master Batman is
the Joker presented in Joker with
Joaquin Phoenix Thank You Edie
dureena so I disagree I I think that as
I said Heath Ledger to me is the
intellectual Joker and Joaquin is the
unhinged Joker in the sense that I'm
pretty when it comes to unpredictability
I get that however we haven't really
talked about the Joker versus Batman
specifically and I think Mark Hamill's
Joker is the most we're talking about
cinematic portrayal here portrayal means
to me what the Joker's essence is and
Mark Hamill did an amazing job not just
being scary with his voice you may not
you yes Heath Ledger and rocky Phoenix
have great physical components that they
added to their performance that are
great however there's a bunch of stuff
that you have to do with your voice and
physically as well to not
come up with funny jokes really creepy
laughs like there's a hole it's
incredible the emotional range that Mark
showed and not just in obviously mascot
fans as I'm Killing Joke animated series
but specifically I think that there's
this emotional dependence between the
Joker and Batman and and it's true and
it's shown in the animated Joker more so
than any other place and because of that
emotional dependence I think that like I
said earlier Heath Ledger's Joker cannot
beat Batman he realizes that he's
uncorruptible Joaquin Phoenix's Joker we
don't even know if he cares about Batman
yet right he doesn't even seem to care
about anything he doesn't care that his
followers are creating chaos he's just
like oh cool this is fine I'm going
crazy because this world sucks oh I
don't care what you do I don't think
he's gonna be a leader or anything like
that
where is Mark Hamill's Joker he actually
represents the chaos and not just all
not just all of us and like our own
inner darkness but he actually is almost
if he's the only Joker to me that
represents like true evil as well and
that could be because of whatever
psychotic disorders he has whether he's
you know as we said he he's like bipolar
he's psychotic if he's a paranoid but to
me he's a true psychopath like he's he's
the one that you don't know how he's
gonna how he's gonna react whether his
relationship with Harley is terrifying
and it's a freakin cartoon right like
that that to me if he wasn't a cartoon
you guys would beat you you guys would
all be [ __ ] your pants there's one
thing can we cuss oops no worries okay
we can edit it that time all right wow
what a great breakdown of these three
iconic Joker's are alright yeah
you're alright but only one is really
right that's not damn facts I mean as
then pointed out this is mostly an
opinion based fight so no no facts other
than I'm sure some people would say why
does Mark Hamill count Batman as the
phantasm was released theatrically on
Christmas Day 1993
that's why Mark Hamill counts as a
cinematic Joker yeah yeah
also lobbying for Joaquin Phoenix's
Joker to be called the Walker
that's our I'm sure I'm not the first
one to come and put that joke but the
Internet sure yeah thank you Dan yeah so
you all put out compelling arguments as
to why your Joker should reign supreme
as the ultimate cinematic portrayal you
know
dureena you really sold the case for
Mark Hamill but just something resonated
with me when they said I think was Greg
mentioned the actor and his body and I
just thought about Heath Ledger and the
licking and then the contortions of
Joaquin Phoenix and it's just in the
portrayal I feel like that just puts
them even though too many people sleep
on mark Hamill's so thank you for
representing an important cause right
here today yeah so for me it came it
came down to Greg and Ed it's you know
it's a slug fight back and fest back and
forth
everybody's land and blows but at the
end of the day Greg said that Ed's
criminal mastermind like you know it was
theoretical that he potentially rallied
everyone at the end and like we have to
make that a to see leap where as we get
the entire package in what Greg broke
down and even though I would like to
hear like a breakdown of this the acting
performances cuz you guys just you know
so much in your arguments but by a hair
I just got a go Greg for the fully
realized version of Heath Ledger's Joker
no I'm kidding
damn yeah it is tough as I mentioned
before and as ed mentioned this is about
an opinion based wedding what values of
the joke are important to you how do you
see the character so I feel like
everybody delineated very clearly what
they love about their version of the
Joker what connects to them why they
think their version is a good portrayal
of it and that's a good aspect of the
argument but when you come down to who's
the winner I think it's got to be the
person that to me delineated theirs in
context of the other two the best and I
think that's why I'm gonna go with Greg
because I think Greg did the best job
not just saying like here's why I think
this joker works well and is good but
also here's why I think this joker
combines this aspect of yours and this
aspect of yours and makes it into this
portrait just the overall picture of why
this portrayal of the character embodied
so many different parts even of other
portrayals is what put it ahead for me
so great arguments very passionately
from everybody who and I think Greg
takes the plate Greg you get that point
Danielle but I want to speak on behalf
of jared leto no one can speak up work
speaks for itself
yes yeah yeah you know what people don't
mention Cesar Romero enough he's a great
story you do not want to say that I do
think Mark Hamill is actually very
nuanced incredible
so Greg Jack Nicholson just once yes
also great absolutely absolutely
scooby-doo version Joker that one house
good one you know what we can listen all
day so Greg's up one nil nil he
initially picked Jared Leto to say
some of the emails alright head injury
now looking to get on the board here's
question numero dos so we asked what
should be the setup for Joker - let's
say joaquin phoenix dons the greasepaint
one more time what should be the setup
and question - we'll start with player
two and alright basically given the fact
that we are in the world that i was just
talking about and we are with a
relatively inexperienced joker i think
one of the main things we have to do is
in the sequel establish how he becomes
you know born again hard and i think
that that's one a big theme of it him
getting in with the misters asses that
the killer crocs the all these people
from harcum asylum basically him being
introduced into the gen pop and and them
and their their whole society in arkham
further hardens him and he gained skills
over the course of subsequent adventures
in there to where he becomes sort of
unnecessary even not necessarily a
leader in there but definitely a wild
card in there to where he can galvanize
people a little bit he and it could even
take place over a few years the first
act you know of him being in there
getting hardened but the bottom line is
the overall thing of it is basically One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest with the
Joker mmm it's him getting the proper
resources together to get out and get
into the general population I start
tearing stuff up that's the overall
thrust of the movie got it thank you
Edie
dureena so my suggestion is actually a
sequel to Ed's and mine is the prequel
to drink
three have created quite a joker so mine
would be about 10 years later after this
joker movie where spoilers I guess Bruce
its older and becoming Batman and in in
this case though because I think Joker
the movie was basically not not just
narrated by an unreliable character
because we're seeing the movie through
the Joker to there Joker's eyes and we
don't know what's true or what's real I
think it'd be great to see a sequel
through Batman's you know what's about
to through Batman's eyes and in this
case what's happening is Joker has
already been at Arkham Asylum he's
gathered his friends you know like we're
talking about he's gathered everybody
he's gathered basically a group of
cronies and similar I would love it if
it was similar to almost got him which
is my favorite up so from Batman and the
animated series where he gathers all of
these caralyn characters that we all
know and and and ends up trying to
defeat the Batman right like so they all
gather I don't know you guys have seen
this episode but they're all gathered
around a table playing poker and they're
all telling their stories about how they
captured Batman and widely and if
whether or not they've defeated him yeah
cool
dureena thank you for that Greg yeah
well when I got this question I was
really reflecting on what joaquin
phoenix and todd phillips specifically
set out to do with their solo Joker
movie installment thematically tonally
and i didn't want to put Batman in it
because todd phillips and both walking
for you know they were both like we know
we don't want to put that man if we ever
do a joker to because i felt that that
would detract so i didn't want to go
along that path i'll be it
those ideas do sound cool there's a fan
of batman but for this version though i
don't i think it would do a disservice
if we actually threw in batman in any
way or any other rogue villains so my
basic log line if i were to like read it
on IMDB would go something like
after becoming a celebrity worshipped
serial killer receiving fan letters and
our command such the absentee leader of
the cult breaks Arthur Fleck out to lead
their cause but they find a difference
in ideologies they perceived from Arthur
versus Arthur's actual motives because
what I find interesting with the way
Haley like I were talking about the last
round is that he had his own personal
agenda with the kills in that movie yet
the way this sort of big cult following
that he has at the end of it their ideas
are all on capitalism politicians they
interpreted his criminal activities as
something completely different than what
he actually did and when he's on that
talk show with Robert DeNiro he even
says I'm not political I don't have an
agenda like how these guys have this
agenda yet somehow his personal motives
gave credence to these riots so I
imagine that not everyone in that group
is you know an unhinged mentally ill
person like Arthur I feel like the way
they interpreted it was that he is
someone who is you know maybe a Robin
Hood of sorts someone who was a fighting
against the evil men in power so what
happens when you break that person out
this person who's like has a celebrity
worship kind of like when we do with
serial killer so I would explore kind of
like that theme in the first half of it
and then when he's out of you know like
then he then you could start segue into
him becoming a criminal leader a
criminal mastermind of sorts that lets
that I wasn't even reading my notes for
the first time and I got cut off that
was right
with the sleep this is the thing okay I
just must push back on this notion of
again that's why I'm structured mind the
way I did is that there is a time for
him to get hard and hard end because
prison frankly the first one is about
how social services and lack of such can
push you into a life of crime or into
criminal activity the next one is about
incarceration and how incarceration and
the but the pathology that hasn't
introduced to you Eva especially if
you're already damn crazy how much more
crazy you are if you're put in with a
bunch of hardened criminals and you're
not really given the chance to
rehabilitate and that is kind of what I
think mine is about rather than your
seems to be almost like being there or
for his gun where he maintains this
childlike know what's going on and it's
just like that that can't hold now he
boarded the course of over the course of
my movie he would become more like a
joke I think at the end of this movie we
see him already become Joker when he's
when he's talking to the social service
person within Arkham Asylum and he says
well you wouldn't get it right you
wouldn't get the joke like he's already
the Joker I think that we don't really I
don't want to see another Batman Begins
for another Man of Steel which is like
an origin story of he's been covering
the Joker I want to see a sequel where
he already is the Joker I those last 30
minutes that we got in the movie a
Fokine actually being the terrifying
unhinged Joker we're talking about I'd
rather see him lead all of the other
Batman's allah-allah long Halloween oh
the other Batman villains and actually
try to fight Batman because yes I know
you're saying that okay we've already
seen bat members as a joker but we
haven't seen this type of Joker fight
the Batman right we haven't seen
somebody that's actually not just that
the Batman could be really really scared
of unlike unlike Heath Ledger like I
don't know how Batman would stop this
Joker and that would be interesting for
me to see my only rebuttal to that is
that in my movie the Joker actually
earns escaping because he must make
relation for all he gets hardened then
he makes relationships and forms the
people like the giant guy Killer Croc
where if I could just break him out he
could bend these bars Oh
doctors mr. zas if I could just get him
out of this great jacket at this time he
could stab these two guys and
to put that together to actually become
more of a mastermind to see it and
manifest it isn't just like oh it begins
begins this is about him graduating and
his graduation present is breaking out
of Arkham and unleashing up on Arkham
much like Bane did in the comic books
during nightfall a new era of a bunch of
weirdos out there and there's nobody to
stop them for another ten years that my
friend is a climate that makes a Batman
it isn't just a it isn't just your
parents getting killed it's the fact
that when you come back from Thailand
wherever you were studying abroad your
cities ruined because all these clowns
are weirdos or what it rabbit knows what
do you check that really I don't see I
don't see any Joker lasting in Arkham
that long they always escape right away
I feel like your guys's movies would
ultimately detract from the focus of
Arthur Fleck though from the focus of
Joker I don't see how your he's I mean
still Arthur if like the identity within
the Joker that you're yeah when you got
when you're talking about like this huge
rogue gallery of villains and that would
be three foot two in in a movie people
are like too much like the four is a
plenty and then that one I feel like we
would be so focused on Batman
specifically I I feel like they're
telling the story through the people the
villains playing poker like it would be
basically the episode that we see where
they're telling the story of Batman but
it's but but Batman but it's so low it's
still like that man movie though this is
what you guys are describing
continuation of it was first described
as being a little bit through Batman's
eyes I did remember that part but also
the thing that that and roll this in
your final thoughts please again I think
it being when you look at the world that
they posited that be or Batman if we're
talking about ten years later it's only
17 18 years old round 18 years old
because he was like I'm sorry no 10 year
olds letting anybody put their fingers
about but like
that kid that kid is just a eight year
old dandy doesn't know too much about
the world has been carried about by his
parents as an ornament his whole life he
doesn't know anything
that person ten years later is gonna be
18 even 20 that person is not gonna be
ready to do anything about anything but
in the world that I'm positing over the
course of that time the city gets worse
and worse so by the time he comes back
at 24 25 26 27 there's a real reason for
him to exist this is not about a Batman
movie it's called Joker - not Batman -
and not not bat and not Joker and the
cult it's called the Joker to myself and
Joker Joker using other people who
aren't even there villain I did it
easier than say the penguin I didn't say
and he said it depend what smack
somebody with a Mac roll for them to get
out of prison I didn't say that
these proto versions of these creepos
are let loose as he graduates and
becomes and gets out into the city that
is a real story beat that could happen
in Joker - - again justify the existence
of a Batman to rise against the city of
weirdo criminals criminals that that
can't be policed by normal policing I'm
setting up that world very capably I
think thank you add dureena so um I like
your version Edie
however the reason I when I when I say
that if we're looking at this movie
through Batman's eyes I mean that
spoilers for the episode of almost
Gotham Batman is dressed as Killer Croc
and he's listening to poison ivy and
penguin and AH and all these other
characters actually tell their stories
about how they beat Batman right that's
the whole point of that episode but I
think it would be interesting to see to
me I want to see the Joker not just with
that man but with all of these other
villains I know that people say you
can't fit them in I disagree I think
that that that episode did such a great
job of actually showing each villains
characterizations perfectly but then
it's a joker episode right so this is
Joker - that we're talking about it's a
Joker episode because he's the one that
actually is is the only one that's able
to mess with that man out of all of them
that the truly he captures Catwoman he
as you were mentioning he's a criminal
mastermind he's this that's the episode
where we actually see that Joker is
Batman's arch nemesis compared to every
other villain that we see and finally
for Joker - I we've seen the sad
depressing
Kien and he did a great job at that but
I want to see the Joker that we all know
not just terrifying but also funny I
want to see the Joker that's more
cartoonish and actually you know taking
pleasure out of causing other people
pain and suffering that's why he's so
scary thanks Johanna great look guys I'm
sorry to say this I feel like what you
guys have pitch is the complete
antithesis to the world that Todd
Phillips and walking Phoenix up
specifically delved into that you can
pull up facts of quotes they've said
about how they don't want Batman to be
in this that if they were to follow up
and want it to be a focus on Joker I
feel like your movies while sound like
cool comic strips or plot heavy but I
don't really feel the thematic elements
being explored anymore I don't really
feel like their character studies
anymore this doesn't feel like a
continuation of the Joker movie that we
just saw this sounds like a cool Batman
story that has Joker in it or the more
row gallery a Batman row Gallery
Batman's villains with Joker in it from
my story I think it'd be interesting to
see a movie where I put it he becomes
the Joker like when he breaks out and
he's with the cult like I call this
movie the cult of Joker because when
they watch him in this leadership
position they have an idea of what he
stands for so what if when he's out
there on the streets it find out that
you know like that he received all the
love and attention at the end of Joker
that he's been seeking the whole movie
and then the joaquin phoenix movie
though when he's standing on the car is
receiving all that love and attention
but instead of revolting to lead the
people in poverty the people who are
upset doing all the riots he actually
doesn't care about them he doesn't care
about them I'd wanted to where you can
actually watch the guy who was mentally
ill unstable evolved into master
manipulator evolved into a selfish thief
in the underworld of Gotham stealing and
killing from the rich bringing Anarchy
to the streets you can still continue
make the Joker isms but keep it within
the Arthur Fleck continuation of the
story he doesn't have a real end goal in
mind like the way how the these riots
seem to be viewing him like what if by
the end of the journey the ones that
that I love what he represented
ultimately abandon him but real
criminals from the seedy underbelly of
Gotham find that there's value
his symbol is stripped away and he
becomes a villain to be feared by the
people of Gotham who once loved him and
then he you see him evolving from just
pure psychopath into criminal mastermind
at the end but keeping a focus on Arthur
Fleck and not distracted by Batman not
distracted by other villains or anything
like that time all right good stuff you
guys
dan take us to the facts on just one
little thing that kind of came up the
the question of Bruce Wayne's age
potentially in a sequel yes well it's
not
I don't believe specifically stated in
the film the actor who played Bruce
Wayne Dante for Olsen was around eight
eight or nine he's currently nine wins
the movie was filmed so that's its
actual age ten years later than he would
be as around 18 good to know good to
know old enough to like some ninja
training yes because we all know you
know you can only get you're kicking ass
license this argument is all of these
are movies that I want to see but I do
want to say that as interesting as all
of these different takes were the only
one and mention it the only one to me
that felt like really a continuation of
the themes of Joker for me was Gregg's
the other ones are very interesting
Joker movies but I feel like they are
more leading us towards the larger
Gotham mythos and the larger Batman
mythos whereas with his it kept it
smaller and more focused on the
character study of Arthur flex so I'm
going with Greg that's one for Greg yeah
I actually I absolutely hear where
you're coming from there just as far as
like it's almost like you took Ed's
logic for the first argument whereas he
was like this he was leading this people
and he became like this unexpected
leader and then you took that and ran
with it to create that cult so I really
liked that connection to the first movie
but edie felt very connected to the
first movie to me as well I loved the
reference of One Flew Over the Cuckoo's
Nest Amy another iconic 70s film to pair
with
the use of taxi driver and was at 81 s
king of comedy and I
I love the lure of drina's story so
great arguments all around at the end I
get Greg did feel really connected to
the movie but I'm I'm really going I
felt Ed's argument just as embracing
more of the world of the Joker and
exploring his education as a criminal so
I'm going add there Dan
I love almost got him it is also my
favorite or up there definitely in the
top five favorites for me of the
animated series but I do agree that it
is it's too much of a it seemed like too
much of a departure away from focusing
at all on the character whereas I know
he is a key player there were so many
other things and things that it's have
happened in between it just felt a
little disconnected so it's between edy
and Greg for me I actually think that
Greg's argument about you know it's a
fun idea but I kind of felt the same way
by that side pitch which was that you
know it sounds fun but you know does it
at all connect with or continue the
storyline of this Joker film and I think
that's what this was it was a pitched
for this joker to and I felt like Greg's
pitch picked up on the themes of the
first film continued what was set up at
the end of it as far as the mobs now
looking to this leader and the fact that
he's not interested in leading these
people and what happens from that and
the idea of just like the other thing
was he's I wasn't sharing the spotlight
which Greg brought up the idea of like
it's not a Batman film and both of the
other pitches I think we're at risk of
becoming Batman films with the Joker
kind of in there
so to me the the the best fit for
continuation of this Joker universe was
Greg so I went with Greg you take the
point - OH
going into question number three well
fought everybody lots of great Joker
knowledge coming out and a lot of good I
mean if I if I was watching this show I
hadn't seen like some of these
references it's just like yeah thank you
for dropping knowledge I can't wait to
hear your pitch for this alright
Wolverine movie Logan that was in many
ways a reworking of Shane and this Joker
film reworking of comedy and taxi driver
so we asked you what classic film should
be reworked to star a classic comic book
character oh yeah that's good stuff
right there and it's question three
let's start with player three
dureena so my pick would be throwback to
Sunset Boulevard
starring Catwoman I think that if
especially we got Michelle Pfeiffer I
mean I would die but if we specifically
got an older cat woman that you know it
and we can have a press member of the
Gotham Gazette for example you know play
Jos part William Holden's part and and
come visit you know Selina a retired
Selina perhaps hopefully from the Batman
Returns one that we saw and and he you
know we go off of that storyline where
he's he's trying to find out did
Catwoman exist you know what is she
doing now does that we can explore
whether or not Batman still exists right
like we can go into so many themes here
but to me Catwoman represents this crazy
she's not just this I feel like a lot of
people put her down as this loves love
interest of Batman and that's not who
she is to meet to me she specifically do
Batman Returns she becomes this this
person this woman that owns her own
womanhood in her sexuality after
realizing that you know society the
patriarchy and society suck in the in in
the Gotham that she lives so I feel like
she's been hiding out for years and
she's making a comeback and that's and
and then this this Gotham gets said
journalist comes and visits her and
eventually you know it'd be cool if he
ended up dying to it
Anderson by her obviously cool yeah a
great first pitch dureena Sunset
Boulevard with Catwoman around the horn
to Greg yeah mine would be a
psychological horror film inspired by
Carrie but I would be focusing on the
character of Jonathan crane aka the
Scarecrow and if you look into the
Jonathan cranes back oh there's
different versions of course but there's
very much similarities to Jonathan
cranes backstory with Carrie in a lot of
ways actually so mine would take place
in the 1970s and I would focus on
Jonathan crane in senior year of high
school and he's someone who is a
completely introverted type of science
nerd and he gets made fun of a lot not
just for his demeanor and the way comes
across before the fact of how he has a
sort of this unusual body features kind
of like Ichabod Crane and in that and so
in in this world where he he so he's
getting bullied a lot basically and and
it also deals a lot with body shaming
which is something that I don't actually
see really done with male young male
characters and movies a lot and I think
would be cool to explore that borrowing
sort of that theme from Carrie as well
in my version he'd also be a closeted
homosexual character who has a crush on
one of the football players one of the
only characters is actually nice to him
but the deeper rooted issues with
Jonathan crane would be that at home his
father who was a biology scientist his
father is traumatized from being someone
who wasn't able to save his wife aka
Jonathan cranes mother from a fire so he
has these Express that he's working on a
developing a cure for fear borrowing
from the comics the father's developing
a cure for fear and this is doing two
fold one fold is that similar to Carrie
were these philosophies become an
abusive form he is developing this
because he thinks fear is the enemy and
also he believes that if he can have his
son overcome the fear he can finally
become a man and stand up for himself
and go after all these things so
borrowing the idea of like abusive
philosophies and also dealing with
bullying and all these sort of thematic
elements you see explored and Carrie as
well before a young male
in 1970s Gotham hi thank you Greg well
we've heard of things like old
gunslingers but we never heard of an old
sword swinger you know I mean so I I
wanted to do Unforgiven with Conan
because I do believe that there's a lot
of mythos in the elder tales of the
Barbarian it isn't just all like saving
gals from zombies and stuff there's a
lot of real world building that happens
from Conan sword like he goes through
areas and changes the way their history
goes and one of the apocryphal tales
about Conan as he becomes the king of
Aquilonia the big america of the
Hyborian age he becomes the king by
strangling the old king on his own
throne and becoming the people champ you
know the AE RVD yeah so basically I want
to see that story I want to see him go
from sort of a washed-up grizzled like
sharpen and his sword keeping a chart
but never using it anymore maybe a
farmer you know sort of that knows sort
of situation because like ah man I
already did it baby come a little plot
of land and then he gets pulled back
into the larger politics of the Hyborian
age and he must use these ultimate
skills that have fallen by the wayside
with advent with you know more currency
more more egalitarian cities more
metropolitan cities there's less and
less barbarians less and less people
like him one barbarian in this new world
was wrapped up in the last 40 years
would be an army on it to itself and
that being pushed back into service to
help humanity for maybe the first time
in his whole life and then his reward at
the end of course is the crown Venice
with a weary brow right on and did you
mention what movie or Unforgiven gran
forgiving great yeah Clint Eastwood's
great Unforgiven all right fight it out
y'all I mean I want to see all these
movies yeah it's all so cool I'm gonna
try to
maybe my thing is I know the reason I
find mine idea interesting is because I
think in Sunset Boulevard Norma Desmond
and a Joe I think they both think that
they can manipulate the other one and
what I like so much about Catwoman as a
character is that you you also she also
is unpredictable right like know what
she's gonna do and if you see a member
it turns like you know max trick kills
her quote-unquote the great Christopher
Walken uh but then when she comes back
and he's he's he's alive she's just kind
of messing with him she's not even you
know mad at him right she's just like
just like go what's up like it's fine I
don't care like that's why I think
Catwoman is scary right and so I think
it'd be really cool to see that
relationship between her and another
male again and and and seeing kind of
her representing you know strong women
that are at the end of the day like
usually pushed over by douchey dudes
none none in this room of course and I
think it'd be cool to see that
perspective
also if we get Michael Keaton showing up
at the end I mean everyone masks I'll
say something good about both you guys's
pitches I love the fact that it's more
like women don't die after 40 you know I
mean I love that that needs to be said
and as in regards to yours I love that
we're getting more number one
inclusivity but also the inclusivity
that could go with trauma you're going
to make a scarecrow and have such a
complicated origin but I do believe it's
sort of trucking a little close to Joker
territory which is why I had to jump all
the way out the bat first with mine and
look at just something I've never seen
before which is Elder fantasy everybody
in the fantasy is some eternal elf and
this sword and all the Old Kings were
just fat and under getting stabbed on
the throne above but it's worth tonight
there you know with about ten weeks of
work could be super old man strong as
he's been in any movie and just really
be able to show like what what what
grizzled fantasy guy would look like
what what the sort of
to live I mean to live to 30 in that a
in that era is insane but to live to 60
how badass would you have to be I mean I
think yeah I think both of the I think
everyone's idea is really cool this is
the most complimentary movie fights
around I've ever been a bargain yeah the
one fight that I mean ADA to kind of
defend my pitch a little bit here is
that the mine is the only one that
hasn't had its own solo adaptation yet
and I feel like there's been several
Catwoman ones there's been several I
would say there's a reason why nobody's
done a bud crane stories I mean Jonathan
crane story my bad well that's why I
want to do this one because I feel like
one of the cool things about Joker was
that they took these themes and these
Story concepts from like taxi driver and
King a comedy that somehow are still
relevant today and I feel like dealing
with these thematic elements of like
abuse attracts abuse and then how when
he's in school and oh I shouldn't really
want to backtrack a little bit
when when you were saying that it's too
similar to like the bad verse but it's
midsummer you told me I just kind of
confused on where you said it's similar
to the Joker in that it is a reasoning
behind this character who we've already
have a lot of familiarity with has been
used capably into pretty good movies
recently but it's just feel like you
know mine's a little fresher but in
terms of I think though that we don't
really we never have seen a origin story
even with Joker he's still an adult I
think you'd be fascinating to go to the
child psychology element of a the origin
of a villain and see how they formed
from there I think you can do a lot of
cool things with the fear toxin elements
of how he's having like nightmares sort
of Eraserhead
another movie for scarecrow because
Carrie to me is I think youyou are right
right that there's that emotional
abusive relationship going on but
there's also religious themes to it and
I feel like the Scarecrow the whole
point is that he's supposed to tap into
a specific fear that all humans have
right right right so like so I roll this
into your final thoughts by the way so
I'm talking please don't interrupt me
sorry I'm kidding
it's an interesting pitch but I would
pick another movie for a scarecrow maybe
like an eraser head maybe like a
Hellraiser version would be really cool
with your pitch
I love Conan except for the snake parts
and I think that that's the reason I
like it too much is because of the
fantastical ass aspects and you if
you're gonna make it into our viewer
like turning it into a Western and then
you're losing all of that right so
that's and also Michael Keaton in
michelle pfeiffer reunion at a senate
post well played Greg well I like that
well I like the story ideas you guys
have I don't really see how borrowing
from the films necessarily whatever
thematic elements those films are you
guys were saying it's in the vein of are
necessarily relevant for today whereas I
feel like mine can be with the social
commentary cautionary tale elements
about that I thought in Joker were great
about mental illness but I also think
this would focus more on how the youth
are treated teen angst and bullying with
this backdrop serving as a cautionary
tale as well I mean it's interesting to
me how on social media it seems like the
Nerds have become the bullies so what if
we went back in time and saw that
another being nerd in school at one
point really wasn't cool and look how
people were treated back then and I feel
like bullying is still a really bad
epidemic that happens today so it'll be
cool to see that I also think it'd be
cool to focus on a character like I said
when he is very young strictly the high
school portion I think you could have
like a really cool finale of this guy
who is sort of it's kind of this weird
arc where he has he embraces his fear by
the end of it but he still doesn't get
what he wants from the people the
approval so he does take his revenge and
kind of having a similar sort of
showdown of Carrie I think you can do a
cool sort of finale like a Halloween
dance where he is like Anne Askew guest
of the Scarecrow outfit and he unleashes
like the fear toxin in there and you
could watch all the people who have
wronged him sort of kill each other or
you know kill themselves or something
like that so and I had
we haven't seen a scarecrow movie yet so
I think it would be cool to just get
finally an origin tale of him that is
actually pertinent for today's standards
thanks Greg
Edie I think that there again I said it
in my argument I think there's a reason
what we haven't had one because I don't
know that the characters
Reidy frame can withstand all of the
stuff that you've put on them nor does
nor do I believe that it that it really
connects with Carey and all that much as
the rena stated the thing about carrie
is there's religious undertones there's
all these different ways her she's
dealing with literally having
telekinetic powers having your daddy
know how to make fear gas it's not the
same as being able to tear apart the
prom with your mind I don't really feel
like they relate with the Catwoman thing
again women don't die after 40 I love
the whole combining them back together I
love all that I love the nostalgia of it
like these were the days the pictures
got small you know that whole thing I
love love love that however with both of
these ideas I think there's a sincere
severe paucity of comic-book action the
whole reason why we're trying to put a
comic book with a classic theme is so
that they can be like like Logan Logan
had Shane skeleton but its own
adamantium endoskeleton along with it
too in its own action vertebrae and I
think that made it be a lot more
acceptable than like an old-school you
know Western just with Logan it had both
things modern comic book actions and old
themes mine has that as well you would
not lose the supernatural aspect of it's
just like it's Game of Thrones it'd be
Game of Thrones Ian in regards to like
you know Unforgiven shot like Game of
Thrones with sort of Game of Thrones and
sort of things happening no dragons
maybe like light magic you know thulsa
doom II sort of stuff
and again the Hyborian age forged the
world we live in right now and I think
just going back and exploring that with
the westerns i with some great action
from 8711 like john wiki and fresh
action and a swashbuckling movie without
a bunch of CGI crap I think it's
something that people would really enjoy
thank you and bam there we go Dan
factually what's up nothing to correct
factually it checks out everything's
good right on dan please want you favor
us with your thoughts on this room yeah
three great movies first of all starting
from
and I love you know modern spins on all
of them
I think Gregg's was Greg had me at the
beginning like his initial pitch
I thought tied in very well but the
further we got from it the further I
think we got a waves it was a little it
felt a little muddled for me when you're
looping in the dad working on the fear I
mean it kind of ties in but it felt like
not quite a match so it was between ed
and Drina for me and Unforgiven old
conan again like when ed started his
pitch I was like totally on board but
then as he went on it really seemed to
tie in more to existing Lord not so much
like here's how I would take Unforgiven
and some of the themes and make this
into a Conan the Barbarian movies more
like I like the concept of an older
Conan which I do too but you know how
does this tie into the movie and it was
taking a classic movie so for me I think
that drew did a good job of you know
Sunset Boulevard the idea of this older
cat woman you know it ties in to the
original it is similar in the sense of
like you're dealing with the same things
of thing you know being past your prime
and moving on and all of that so to me
it was the the best tie-in between the
source material this comic book
character how you're gonna do it I
argument against it and really resonate
with me because Joker didn't really have
any comic book action in it either and
this is about sort of spending a
character off in a new direction so
Terenas pitch was the one that I'm going
with this for my vision thank you Dan
that's one for dureena Danielle please
let us know all your thoughts yeah all
of these were super great I have to
agree where Greg's was a fantastic pitch
and then yeah it cut a little bit
squishy for me
I felt it when I was talking for me and
it was so he I was between dureena and
and and I have to say I agree with Dan I
really as much as I love old man Conan
because it does sound really interesting
I would like to see like an older Arnie
kind of step up I didn't feel as much of
the Unforgiven in that as I did just you
know which was greater the themes were
fantastic I didn't feel as much of like
the bones of Unforgiven or as Dorina
felt very clear about how it would be
how she would relate and then spin off
from Sunset Boulevard so go Mina great
dureena you get the point
one line for your movie I'm ready for my
close-up Commissioner Gordon
Commissioner go ahead do it do it yeah I
wouldn't touch you to scratch you you
know what I think
so it's Greg to Doreen Awan Edie looking
to get on the board here we go question
number four so the the genius that is
Martin Scorsese he controversial he said
that he is not a big fan of comic book
movies so the more like a theme park
ride so we asked what comic book or
graphic novel adaptation would you show
to Martin Scorsese they'll tack on at
the end to change his mind to be like
what are you thinking if they're if
they're if you else think should his
mind be changed that's a whole nother
question but we asked what would you
show him to change his mind Greg start
us off
yeah it shows a movie that I think is
poetic haunting visually effective in
its storytelling this is a to me one of
my favorite movies of all time and that
is Sam Mendes is road to perdition the
story follows a mob enforcer sunny
witnesses a murder
forcing him and his father to take the
road and his father down a path of
redemption and revenge
I mean first off this movie is just
gorgeously shot it's one of the most
beautifully shot films I've ever seen
and going off of Scorsese's quote
of talking about how I have it I have it
right here about how it's trying to
convey emotional psychological
experiences to another human being and
how these movies are theme parks this
movie is the antithesis of being a theme
park comic book movie it is purely
character driven every relationship in
here is extremely complex
it's as if explores these themes of what
it mean for what it means for a father
to be a son and there's so many good
visual storytelling moments that don't
rely on dialogue at all the action
sequences all have true purpose behind
it and the performance is all around Tom
Hanks Paul Newman Daniel Craig Jude
Law's really Angela I think is a great
example of how to do like a Dick Tracy
like villain but make him truly
realistic and believable
so you know like going with this
question do I think we can you know
convince Scorsese to go watch a bunch of
Marvel movies probably not but I think
this can encourage him to go check out
more comic-book movies like this one or
perhaps encourage people to go watch
movies like this one thanks Greg Edie
well you know this is kind of rough
because I thought I would have won a
plane by now and I would have a little
bit more room to play with this question
so that being the case black panther I
would show them that because number one
and be probably the first time you saw a
movie with that many black people in it
number two
[Music]
you talk about the father and son the
whole jazz you know what I mean
there's father and son stuff all through
this movie and I do believe that he
would at least try to relate to the to
the Shakespearean themes of you know the
King Lear of it all you know I made me
kind of you know Ryan Coogler saw a kind
of cure of course how a film do you like
that
you know I this is the patron most
patronizing did the fact that we have to
care but not about what a great
filmmaker thinks no no he's a great
filmmaker yes what top one or two my
personal opinion oh yeah but why why is
everybody very what why do we have to
change anybody's mind about any of this
stuff it's making a billion dollars none
cause this questions kind Victor's for
once in your life
we won we've won we're suffering at the
carcass of these are not gonna rest
until everyone appreciated when we get
branded as one of us one of us types
we're gonna go no no it's much more not
once than that
well doesn't appear to be for this
verdict
so in closing for my first part here
yeah Black Panther does have real themes
one of the greatest screenplays in the
whole Marvel who've arrived
I'd say the screenplay stacks up right
along with Winter Soldier or any of that
stuff and it's basically it has it has
the task of doing an origin story
without being boring yeah as a task of
showing a whole new culture it has a
task of showing how that culture relates
to greater you know culture in the world
and I would just have him watch that
movie and at the very end when he's
going and I really like I say now
imagine they were all Italian and watch
him go
I could I liked it dureena what he got
so um I think I wouldn't show I mean I
would let him show me whatever movie he
wanted on this let's be honest but um if
I wanted to convince Martin Scorsese
that there are good and entertaining
comic-book movies out there because I
think you guys are kind of at different
opposites for me you have a very serious
comic book Greg does here at where as
Edie has more of like the fun it even
even though really good but it's more a
fun action type comic book I would go in
the middle and so my choice would be V
for Vendetta V for Vendetta has
everything it's not just a great
beautifully shot movie with an amazing
score by Daria marinelli which I think
Martin Scorsese would appreciate but it
has themes that I think he would be
interested in that you know the people
becoming anarchists and and an
anti-establishment and trying to fight
the government the cast is excellent
Stephen Fry John Hurt these are people
you go we being these are people that I
think Marty would would respect and also
be impressed by their by their
characters in this John Hurt is a total
dick in this movie he's a very scary
villain and a very real villain that we
all live live with every day right now
apparently and additionally Martin
Scorsese is known fourth grade
soundtracks and this is V for Vendetta
literally did the best use of
Tchaikovsky's 1812 overture at the
that's one of the coolest scenes in any
movie at the end when they blow up the
Big Ben and all the the crowd is
gathered there with with the V mass I
just think it's it's a really fun and
smart movie that we can all relate to
and I think that that would be
entertaining to him if he would think it
smart but also know that there's some
action sequences on there that aren't
just mindless you know CG monsters
fighting superheroes so I think you
would enjoy it mix it up y'all I mean
though isn't there a scene when Hugo
Weaving throws like a CGI knife or
something and cuts around everyone in
there it's still like really elaborate
CGI kind of happen
I feel like when these two movies they
still fall under the category of what
Mart I think there are better than just
theme park movies but I can still see
Martin Scorsese going and being like no
there's the big takeaways with these
movies tend to still be the visual
spectacles V for Vendetta less character
more political commentary I would say
one thing just just as one tiny rebuttal
though you don't change people's minds
by showing the the inventive thing you
want to show and it's least inventive
form right
you don't show somebody you know you
don't convert somebody to basketball by
showing them something that's not quite
to basketball and Road to Perdition
could have been based upon anything
whereas both of our movies at least must
have been based upon a comic book Road
to Perdition didn't have to be based
upon a graphic novel that could it's a
great movie but it's if you show it to
Martin Scorsese he's not gonna know it's
a comic book movie unless you tell him
it isn't the whole point that he can
exceed past what a comic convince him to
watch other comic book movies via Road
to Perdition which is which is more of a
typical dramatic I mean I don't agree
with that when I watch Road to Perdition
to me it is the most strikingly visual
movie from pulling out these framing
devices the way the cinematographer
composed like the whole photography of
the film looks like a moving panel well
you're gonna go with looks like a comic
if you're gonna go with the visual movie
that would please I might aesthetically
then go with Sin City in that case not
the emotional site I'm trying to
encompass everything that Martin
Scorsese's I get and let's argue about
this here let's argue about our movies I
believe realistically story-wise March
Scorsese would like my movie because
frankly you can a lot of the characters
are analogous to ones he's explored
before in main street you got the
character of Johnny boy Johnny boy is
too damn crazy
you can't corral them that's sort of
like that's a little bit like he'll
monger and a little bit like some of the
people who are more zealous in his
regime you got you got people who are
like rats there's rats in this story
that
you know I don't think I don't think
Martin Scorsese would sit through the
last third of Black Panther I think he
would turn it off as soon as I Berger
and Black Panther are fighting in that
movie the movie is just CG stuff in
black panther still there's still a big
giant film with a like a lot of
explosions and stuff and like I said the
character ization is the last thing
people take away from V for Vendetta
right you want to talk about a move a
comic-book adaptation that is in tune
with Scorsese films this is a mob family
period piece in the East Coast and it's
catchy and explores father and son
themes mob story about family is like
what Scorsese excels at but what makes
this different is it's not captured at
all like how Scorsese when I listen to
your final thoughts Greg well that's
pretty much about around my final
thought right there racism as mine is
the movie that has like the Oscar
nominations it's got the great directing
the great writing the incredible
connected performances I mean you're
watching this story of Tom Hanks who's
distant from his son who through his son
learning the truth they start becoming
closer but every time he kills it puts
it makes it makes it even further a
bigger dent in their relationship from
being able to view him as a father it's
some it's thematically on point like the
Catholic things the Richard Scorsese
loves to explore in his movies - I think
this would be the one that connects with
him the most because the whole point is
we're not gonna be like what you were
talking about in your opening rant we
can't convince Martin Scorsese and
there's no point in trying to do that
but what if we can sway him in a way to
show hey there's more kinds of comic
book movies then Marvel there's more
kinds of compromise than the DC ones
look at these ones and promote those and
then maybe with Scorsese backing that we
can get more of these kind of graphic
novel adaptations thanks Greg Edie yeah
all I'm saying is Pisa okay I'm trying
to change him right there's no what I'm
I'm trying to do could this whole like
half-ass appeasement like oh yes sir I
have this almost gangster movie I don't
get that I don't get I don't get V
Vendetta Vendetta because I don't think
he would I don't think he would
appreciate the greater revolutionary
themes in it but I think anybody could
talk about the the family aspect of
Black Panther and also a hidden society
the Cosa Nostra anybody like there are
hidden societies with hidden rules and
all these ritual rituals that give them
a certain power and when those are
opened up to the light of day all types
of stories happen because the
uninitiated don't understand how to deal
with that that's literally the story of
the Mafia in America and every single
depiction of them and it's the same in
regards to the continents and black
panther their very existence challenges
the way that we look at the world so
like I just think that if I'm going to
try to change his mind if I'm gonna try
to show him something outside of his
purview I can't do better than a movie
Chuck full of technological Africans
that's that's the the last thing he'd
want to watch and that's why I would
want to make him watch it thanks dad
dureena that's the subtitle the black I
really enjoy both of those movies that
you guys are pitching but I I think that
black panther what you're saying about
it yes I agree with all those themes and
yes we all see them there's no way Marty
is still gonna sit through that movie
because as much as that movie has
important themes that we can all relate
to and and they're fascinating and are
and are relevant to our society that
you're not you're gonna lose them as
soon as they go into the MCU style
filmmaking aspect of making things funny
and and joking and and and and and also
these movies end up still being for kids
right I don't think Martin Scorsese
watches family movies so on that note
with Road to Perdition I stick to my
point I think V for Vendetta is a good
mixture of both of these movies where
you have a really fun MCU type movie
that we all watch that's like a popcorn
blockbuster that's good but then you
have R Edition that I think Martin could
probably look at
movie and say that's a good movie that I
could have made I think he'd be more
interested in seeing something different
that he's actually interested in and V
for Vendetta is a good mixture of having
political themes that are relevant to
our society as well as not a bunch of
boring CG action sequences that he would
turn it off for I think he would love
the performances I think he would love
John John Hurt basically acting like a
Hitler is scary and terrifying and
relevant and I think he would love the
soundtrack and because he's a music guy
there you go
boom Thank You dureena that is time Dan
facts so what are they well my fact my
fact-checking ties into my judgement so
I'll let you know I'll leave it to house
why don't you roll right into it yeah
okay so yeah okay so I agree with the
foundation of Ed's argument about Black
Panther and that it would be the last
thing that Martin Scorsese would want to
watch because he is first of all a great
champion of world cinema just last year
he remastered through his foundation of
film from Senegal and and championed it
and gave it a premiere at can and it was
very upfront about how important he
thought the movie was he his listed do
the right thing as one of the 85 films
that you have to see if you want to know
anything about film and what he really
said an extensive list of his favorite
movies and the most recent phone in that
list was black Klansmen so I just
disagree with this entire assertion that
Martin Scorsese would never want to
watch a movie with a large number of
black people in it because it's simply
not true
he's been a champion for many films from
black filmmakers and and is a great
advocate of voices from films around the
world so I disagree with that assertion
and I think they feel like the black
panther choice was was predicated and I
think even the the final argument there
brought that argument back I just don't
think that that has a factual basis so
it was between Greg and dureena for me
and I actually would go it was close but
in the final closing arguments I think
dureena won me over just in the sense
that if he's sitting and he's looking at
a movie
he may be more drawn to something that
perhaps shows something that's a little
bit more of a departure than some of the
things that he's done that perhaps he
could see some new DNA and so I'd go
with Dorina and by the way I pitched
this question it's you know the question
that was perfect no I mean his thoughts
on comic book movies did set the
Twittersphere on fire and you know
nothing's gonna get squirts turn
Scorsese so he's like I love I love
comic book movies now I want the Snyder
cut you know please can I please clarify
one thing I'm not saying here's a racist
yeah I'm saying have one black lead ever
so I'm saying yes no listen I think Dan
made a nice clarification and like we're
separating the man from his films like I
I'm trying to think of people of color
in Martin Scorsese films I can think of
Samuel Jackson and Goodfellas it's not a
long list so I think you both made great
point so I don't think it for a second
you were saying the man was racially
insensitive
actually save that soundbite where both
y'all are coming from um at the end of
the day I I agree with Dan I thought the
best case was made for V for Vendetta I
think that like was that like I think
you kind of just split the gap right
there and gave us the proper gateway
drug for Martin Scorsese when it comes
to comic book movies I think you listed
a lot of the elements that would draw
him to it good stuff from both you guys
but yeah I'm going to Reena so we're all
tied up a great moment in sports it is 2
2 and I'm so hungry we are still looking
to get on the board 2 2 would have been
better if it starred old Will Smith all
right
inspired by Gemini man where you get
computer-generated young Will Smith
versus old Will Smith and let's start
with that ok my pick is Independence Day
because I think it is the movie where
him being older could actually add to
the story if indeed we were coming into
the story with an older Will Smith I
think he may have been able to have a
little bit of previous contact with the
aliens maybe though I understand that it
may be an overused plot but sometimes I
love I saw something I saw it and you
guys are acting like I didn't see it and
I'm going crazy and then the whole
world's about the end they go oh you
know that thing you saw come down and
join this elite team of dudes who can
fly this stuff and I think it would have
really helped to explain how Will Smith
could fly their machinery so quickly if
they had a maybe ha ha maybe maybe if
they had a got some sort of either they
had previous knowledge of it and he was
introduced to the threat a little bit
before it came to earth maybe something
like that I think these straight can fly
the Millenium problem
don't get them started right but that's
all I'm saying I think with an older
Will Smith they would have had more
opportunities to write more plausible
reasons for a lot of things like oh hey
i'm part of the alien fighting squad we
never thought would have to exist and
now that it does oh my god this is crazy
I think that would be more the flavor of
it and I think would make a lot more
sense his involvement it wouldn't be so
chance it would be an actual he is the
man for the job got a situation all
right welcome to earth dureena so I am
going with hitch because who ever seen
it it's basically Will Smith being a
professional dating consultant my dream
job I think I should get paid for that I
as much as charming as will is and as
loveable as awesome as he is I think and
I I'm just gonna say I think older men
are attractive
so if if you if he was older and wiser I
would find the movie a little bit more
believable especially with someone like
ever Mendes cuz you know there you go
all right an older more charming Will
Smith's a little gray on the dome Greg
yeah my pick make a wick Wow Wow West
Bay Bay yeah I I love doing that song of
karaoke
you don't want to see my hand worry my
hip so this movie I thought it was kind
of weird when I was sure there's some
script problems with the film why not
I enjoy the movie personally but I think
it would have worked stronger it kind of
didn't make sense to me that the young
gunslinger is the one who isn't a fan of
technological advancements and the old
guy is the one who is it is not you know
traditional and he's all about the crazy
inventions and stuff but beyond that
beyond that little thing I think that
Will Smith if he was older in that film
but the actor that he is evolved into a
better performance automatically makes a
better movie
and this is the only movie I think
between the three of these it actually
needs to be better because in that film
is character has this really traumatic
background and sure it's a comedy but
Will Smith of today can still play
tragic backstory and still elevate a
material in a sort of humorous way if
needed and when he's like telling the
whole story when they like kill that
scorpion or something like that when
they're eating food with Kevin Kline I
don't feel any of that emotional depth
with him that he can provide for sure
today as an older actor a more
experienced actor that movie only has
the charms of Will Smith the funniness
at Will Smith the cool guy Will Smith
but yet he's got this totally tragic
backstory that an older Will Smith would
most definitely be able to provide
include into his performance whereas I
think with your guys's movies they're
both well-received by critics well
received by audiences box-office hits
mine is the one that is a failure all
around and needs actual improv let's
open it up to everybody I would say that
they're not gonna make 24 years of Will
Smith they're just not gonna do that
like this whole the older Will Smith
would make his backstory way too tragic
and a lot of the aspects of his initial
let's call it an indentured servitude so
I'm a peasant anybody off a lot a lot of
that would have been really terrible to
try to include into this giant spiders
off-color family guy asked fart jokes
and sex jokes and then oh he was also
like you know a servant for 24 years
wait yeah that's a lot the way you're
trying to do one movie the way you're
talking about changing Will Smith
affecting the way your plot unfolds in
the movie is the same way I'm talking
about how you could change the way my
movie is personally executed your movie
already has a character like that it's
called Randy Quaid he he's the guy who's
like has the whole thing with the aliens
in the background and with your per
touch of hich it just sounds like the
same exact movie but you would just find
him personally more attractive
but the point is I would trust somebody
if somebody's giving me a professional
dating advice I'm not gonna trust some
young dude I'm gonna trust an older
person what woman are male
additionally the question is we would be
better wouldn't it would be better right
Independence Day would not be better if
he was if he was older because the hope
I love the relate my favorite part of
that movie is the relationship between
most meth and Jeff Goldblum's character
and I feel like Jeff Goldblum is
actually kind of like the older version
of Will Smith and he's kind of you know
their counterparts to each other and so
I think that makes of that relationship
makes a movie better that he's kind of
like leading him to you know to be a
badass basically but it just has one
tiny rebuttal to that though I do
believe it's more like scientist guy and
pilot guy is their dynamic rather than
old and young
I think scientist got a pilot guy might
make that relationship more different
yeah you're right I guess what I mean
more so is the type of personalities of
the dream by by older I mean like Jeff
Goldblum has this you know he's a little
bit more cynical right like like Will
Smith's character supposed to be like
the heroic young kid that's less scared
and and just dust things and they're
just punches aliens right so uh so I
think we would lose that character if he
was older wha-wha West would not be
better at all because that is a horrible
movie even if you had a no Will Smith
you would still have the same issues
that that movie has which is boring and
also if we didn't have that movie we
would have the death of Superman lives
which but with Nicholas Cage and
Superman
so that budget actually that the movie
by Tim Burton were Nicolas Cage was
gonna be Superman what was cancelled and
that budget went to well well twist so f
that movie anything else make this your
final thoughts
and hitch its diplomatic comedy it's a
simple movie but I find wiser people
more believable to give I don't know
that that's I'm done I'm tired thank you
yeah you guys have literally giving me
nothing really specific that would
actually enhance the movie in terms of
what would old Will Smith bring today
bring to that movie now I'm talking
about an actor who is much like wah wah
Wes was very early on in his career a
little bit after Independence Day which
by the way launched him to movie star
stardom was Independence Day hitch was a
great romantic common I think he's the
right age in that movie he's like the
perfect age in that film in terms of the
context of the storytelling
wha-wha wes is the only one between
these three that actually needs some
improvement and there are so many movies
we could think of that are like the
movies okay but I recommend it because
of this performance and Will Smith could
have brought that and I think it would
have made the dynamics make a lot more
sense for the old gunslinger who's a
little bit more set in his ways and who
and it would give more pathos and depth
to the idea that he has been hunting
Kenneth Branagh for this whole frickin
time
and he's so much older in his years it's
just for me that's the one that actually
is applicable and needed whereas these
are great and what do you got well just
because yours is so bad that it can be
helped does it mean that you win I'm
sorry I do believe that my movie
especially Independence Day would be
better because again I'm 24 year old guy
of me and my girlfriend we're just
kicking it and then I'm gonna go fly
this alien craft I just don't get that
but like if he's a little bit older I
think that there's more reason for him
to have that much security clearance
I think there's reason for him to be in
some of these halls of power rather than
oh I happened to run into the first one
and I beat it up in the desert no he's
got security plans because he said he's
old and he's and he's grizzled and he's
risen up the ranks but he's sort of a
button-pusher and then this is pushes
him back into it baby you know that the
added age could help some of those
scenes with some of the experiences he
has I think an experienced pilot having
that adventure sells it more a hitch he
has arguably more Hansel with the great
temples but I don't know how that helps
it and
West you could cast Jesus and well well
West it wouldn't get better so I don't
know performer me check on Jesus alright
and we're there any facts in this round
um just for context will submit 51 years
old today as we sit here
yeah and speak he was 36 years old when
hitch came out 30 when wild wild west
was at least 27 years old when an
offense they came out it makes me feel
like a failure in estate and hich were
critical hits I would say they were
tolerated by critics
they were tolerated by critics their
friend and then I looked this up because
I had forgotten this but yeah it is true
that much of the budget according to
several reports for the deaths of
Superman lives much of that was indeed
shifted to the production of wild wild
west so a butterfly effect lives on the
spider effect I guess them for that
reason alone okay Danielle will you kick
it off here please alright um as precise
and scalpel like which I didn't mention
in the last round as Dorina was this one
I I you great arguments but it did seem
to really lean on I think he would be
super hot
you're right and you great older and
they hammered you with very well that
one as well
and as much I really like chores but I
just Greg really knocked you when he
mentioned that that was just Randy
Quaid's character which was like a which
was a harsh knock out with Greg you just
he had more of a 360 about why it would
work young guys should like the tech you
know old guys should that should you
know be in to be more grizzled he might
have more experience in some of those
other realms and you had like good to
Ed's point it would be weird but there's
all the sudden all this really deep
slavery stuff that's already baked in
there though which is a very weird part
of the movie and he also I agree yours
is the only one that needs anything just
something for Greg yeah you know what
Danielle get out of my head because you
pretty much said like all the stuff that
I thought about this round yes older
Will Smith is fine as hell but I don't
know how that's gonna make the movie
better and yeah I thought I thought Greg
Greg's I mean the major point that hit
home for me was like that yeah that was
that movies the only real stinkeroo and
this might help it out so that was very
necessary so after five rounds Greg and
dureena are going into the speed round
at three to Ed I look forward to seeing
what you're gonna draw yeah it's gonna
be a good car ride
[Music]
well fought all the way so we're going
to the speed round it works thusly I'll
ask the question then the first person
to answer will get 20 seconds to
elaborate then we'll have another 20
seconds and then we'll get to ten-second
rebuttals in that same order and it's
you standing should I stand I'm just a 5
it's let's go to 10 it's it's it's it's
different cuz it's like you got to get
an insurmountable lead so I'll I'll keep
track of it and it'll be gosh I don't
know math right
but what's charting with Dan every
Monday ok have five questions yes we
could answer up to 5 questions ok
whoever amass is an insurmountable lead
that's what happens when you go from 3
regular round questions like two years
if someone gets to 6 okay okay
first to say thank you ryan standing we
weren't sure I'm sorry yes sorry all
right
first question oh you shout out your
answer shout out your answer yeah
El Camino Breaking Bad movie is out now
on Netflix so we ask what other TV
series should get a movie follow-up Six
Feet Under
the defenders the defenders six feet
under here at 60 oh they're sorry to
move you follow up right yes all right
whenever you're ready during a 20
seconds on the clock Oh a six feet under
is if not the best one of the best shows
we've ever seen which had a beautiful
ending it doesn't necessarily need a
movie specific to those characters but I
think it would be cool as a spin-off
similar to better call Saul where it
could be a prequel maybe we can see the
relationship
the the sons with the father before he
died at the funeral home in them growing
up okay I mean you just said it doesn't
need a movie specifically whereas I
think the defenders they didn't get a
chance to close out what they did there
was a large fanbase invested in that
crossover and the crossover didn't live
up so if you were to get a movie where
you can actually close it out be able to
get some closure and say goodbye to the
characters that we all grew to love and
invested so much time it would be
worthwhile ten second rebuttal the
defenders I love all the characters
however it was still a weak show to me
as much as I loved Jessica Jones and
daredevil and and Luke a giant fist not
so much I think that they're all great
actors that was those fast
yeah ten seconds that's my point there
are all great characters the shows were
great and the thing is the crossover
didn't live up but if you can properly
focus it and make a great send-off movie
that would be the ultimate reward and we
could finally move on to Disney Plus
with no worries
time time time alright so yes a
20-second initial answer ten second
rebuttal you know what I absolutely was
gonna go with dureena because six feet
under is an underappreciated gem of a
show but the argument from Greg was
better so I'm going Greg with defenders
Dan yeah I have to agree I think that
Greg argued for the reason that the
necessary that the necessity of this
movie whereas I think that image doing
this sort of is like well it had a great
ending and ultimately I'm going with
Greg as well boom there we go it is four
to Greg in the lead question number two
its speed around here comes in and out
who who should play young detective
Alonso Harris in the recently announced
training day prequel
what a great question
chadwick boseman I'm gonna go with
Michael B Jordan what's gonna be one of
those two Michael B on deck Greg started
off twenty seconds on the clock I think
it would be an honor chadwick boseman
Anika fact check this was able to attend
the acting school he went to because
Denzel Washington's I paid for this
sponsorship or whatever the hell that's
called so you can scholar so he can
actually go so in he's clearly he is a
mainly inspired by Denzel Washington for
the career that he has chosen
he's more akin to Denzel it would just
make a lot more sense in that department
I think Michael B Jordan is not only
would look the part because it's a
prequel and we're talking about younger
but he's chat wakes a great actor but
Michael B Jordan we seen him be amazing
in crappy movies like Fantastic Four so
there you go it doesn't matter what
movie he met he makes he's great in it
and he's a very multifaceted and has a I
think much larger range I agree Michael
B Jordans a great actor but if you look
at the the actual look of chadwick
boseman the hair the body type
everything about him and the way his
cadence the way he delivers his lines
and it's like actual American accent
sounds like Denzel Washington I mean in
that game decades and you go with his
son right because we're talking about
look-alikes so so there's that but what
I think Michael B I think Michael B
Jordan is still I think the better actor
I think chadwick boseman I haven't seen
his range as much time okay Danielle oh
yeah this one was really difficult both
of those are great great choices I feel
like I heard from great I heard more
about like wow this would be an honor
for him and maybe like body type and
speech is a little much
whereas I feel like I heard from dureena
a little bit more about good reasons for
the casting aside from sentimental stuff
and it's true he is younger I do think
he has a great range so for those
specific reasons I'm going with Drita
okay this one for dureena Dan I think I
would actually I thought Greg was
had it fairly well on hand but then
dureena really closed the gap there at
the end
making a lot harder for me to decide I
think ultimately I still barely am gonna
go with Greg but that that last argument
was really strong it almost swayed me
over to during this site yeah it
actually it actually swayed me just I
thought the going with John David
Washington instead if you wanted like
really harken into like some of the
elements that Greg was talking about and
she hit like just the tactical acting
effective so yeah dureena closing the
gap in the game alright so question
three Disney is reportedly working on a
new live-action Inspector Gadget and
come be Matthew Broderick who should
play the new Inspector Gadget hard five
for Chris Evans three yeah Bill Hader
okay Evans hater we heard Chris Evans
first 20 seconds we can when you speak
dureena Chris Evans we've seen him
obviously all as Captain America and
he's great at that but I miss his
comedic skills and we just saw it I
recently had knives out I miss him and
Scott Pilgrim he was this hilarious
douchebag I think he he can play both
comedy and drama really well and I also
think he would be more prone to doing
this movie than someone like Bill Hader
who's doing more serious stuff I mean
Bill Hader is about to be on the Disney
Plus movie with Anna Kendrick so I don't
think that this is something that he
would stay away from but I think his
work in Barry really does showcase that
he is someone who's great at the
investigative kind of roles but then you
back it with that comedic Sensibility
that dry kind of humor that Bill Hader
has you would get the best of both
worlds I think within an Inspector
Gadget of Bill Hader was Chris Evans
okay second so I think because he's
already busy with that Anna Kendrick
movie I think that's a voice acting role
or is it a real role I'm not sure
okay so then never mind the point is
that I think Chris Evans would be more
prone to doing something comedic because
Bill Hader has been doing an SNL forever
time okay
Greg I mean he hasn't been a series
regular on SNL for years whereas I think
with with the Chris Evans he's trying to
depart into a lot more serious roles
smaller roles whereas Bill hader's
trying to and he needs a big
groundbreaking movie role and Inspector
Gadget could be it time okay well some
good stuff I think
dureena we got caught up in the the
rebuttal trying to ask a question of
[Laughter]
your argument around Barry and just your
overall choice of Haider really
resonated with me so I'm going Greg on
this one Danielle yeah I think that
these they were both really good points
I do think that with one of the reasons
why I just think that Greg hit it when
he mentioned that Chris Evans is trying
to do smaller stuff Bill Hader does need
a breakout film and that his dry humor
might really offer itself to something
like an Inspector Gadget so I am going
quickly boom Greg is up five two three
this is now game point for Greg question
number four the speed round here she
comes
who would you most want to see direct a
movie in the John wick verse the wick
averse wick first with the verse would
you also want to see the rectum movie in
the John wick verse not not like a
sequel but just a universe movie in the
John wick verse could be a sequel it
could be just a story about the hotel
could me Ruby Rose's origin story I
don't know but it's in the John waiting
for these questions so hard
five four three two you're gonna want to
say it director before I say one John
John will I'm gonna go with James
Cameron okay we got we wick and Cameron
wick all right Greg on the clock for
John Woo John Woo has made some of the
best Hong Kong gongfu
a kind of action movies ever and yet in
the American cinema he hasn't really had
the chance to really prove himself again
he had like face-off which was cool
broken alright but ever since then it
hasn't been too great he deserves a
comeback James Cameron's way too busy
with like 14 different avatar movies
he's really got his pile stacked up
where John Woo could you actually use
this for surgeons and go back to who is
available because yes it's true that
James Cameron is doing all these dumb
avatar sequels but I would rather have
him to come back to action I think that
I love aliens Terminator 2 obviously
like these are great movies that became
classics because of his director's view
for action and I think we're missing
that a little bit as much as John week
movies are amazing payment if you look
at the James Cameron action movies
they're a really big explosion heavy
whereas John Woo he is about gunplay
which is what John wick is required to
do so if you want something that's
similar but different
Jambu is the perfect segue yeah but I
don't really want to see you know John
wick fighting with an explosion in the
background and then dove flying
book-like above his head as much as I
love John Woo the same time
yeah damn it I have to go first okay
ooh wow this is this is this is this is
this is difficult it's called a tie I
[Music]
think by a very small margin
I think dureena wanted me over with
James Cameron returning back to the
action routes with aliens Terminator 2
the success he's found in the genre and
then the little that little flick there
on John Woo and the very closest one for
Karina that's for TV I'll get taco so
both of these were great great choices I
want to see all of these I will say that
Greg really had me on gun foo action
deserves like a chance to make those big
movies like the ones that he was making
in the 90s again and get something
really on there I both of these I want
to see them Greg for me made a better
case for why John would be a better fit
one for Drina one for Greg yeah at the
end of the day I got a UH to the man who
started at all John Woo - I'd love to
see him direct the biggest gun foo
franchise right now I thought we made
some good arguments and I love hearing
John will get dinged on that
finding the for sure great argument but
I gotta go Greg Greg you just one movie
fight well playing everybody great isn't
shout-outs it's 9 p.m. guys go to bed
yeah no I wanna I want to thank you guys
for giving me such such an entertaining
game today and as much jokes as I'm
making it just a bit I really love being
here everyone knows I love being here
right on hey Ellie Comic Con you guys
are first yeah yeah and go ahead and
plug some LA Comic Con oh well actually
yes weekend as you're watching this this
this weekend as you're watching it now
watch this on your phone on the way down
no but this has been really great and I
both these Confederate errs are really
awesome and I really I'm very happy to
have been here and and we're doing a
thing called how to reboot Batman it's a
panel that we're doing at 2:30 on Sunday
and room 406 a B that's a pretty big
room baby so I would really love for you
guys to come down and support me hey at
my Scorsese takes with too hot come down
politely for an hour and then tell me
about it later love that you know so
it's it's really an interesting project
that Billy business and the nerd goat
crew are doing as a joint venture and
it's just really kind of taking some of
these things where you're just like oh
no why would you reboot that stop it
well you know they're gonna do it anyway
I why not have it done entertainingly in
about an hour in front of you so it's
like it's it's a really a unique show
and I would love it's a it's the launch
of a whole new venture so I would love
for all the screen junkies fans that
like me like my caustic takes yeah come
down and check me out with with some
more hopeful people as we create a new a
new franchise in front of your eyes that
sounds super awesome Batman Sunday hell
yeah
Sunday 2:30 at the LA Comic Con dureena
great stuff today all day long please
tell us where we can find you get some
shout outs I will also be at La Comic
Con this weekend yeah I'm Sunday I have
two panels going on you can follow my
social media for that on Twitter and
Instagram it I'm at evil dureena we have
a
really cool a pop culture needle drop
panel that's basically about the film
music and TV video game music that were
there were there were gonna have at
12:30 I believe so please walk come and
you come here there thank you so much
for having me this was really fun I was
nervous at first but then you guys are
awesome and hilarious so I hope put us
on the ropes man right you're freaking
great thank you thank you ah the damn
cam thank you for holding it down you
guys please I pleasure Dan who's gonna
take the box office this weekend Oh
looks like it looks likes gonna be Joker
again but you got Gemini man coming in
and move owns an Addams Family and all
kinds of stuff contenders in there now
Joker's doing really well with some good
good week days and yeah by the time this
comes out we'll know but we don't know
this we're filming also just a shout out
you wouldn't know how good my movie
fight rival with Edgar is even when
we're not competing against each other
we still thank you for being just
awesome as hell please tell us where we
can find you etcetera find me on twitter
at daniel Radford find me on instagram
at daniel underscore radford if you like
wrestling I have a podcast called tights
and fights
also something you should be looking at
on right here this channel the screen
junkies
we have released our latest episode of
power levels it's amazing it's called
Batman V Batman V Batman we literally
took a very smart person a physicist we
may then look and do the math about
which is the best film version of Batman
it's really fun it's really funny
everyone worked so hard on it if you
liked the original episode that we did
what we talked about the Dragons or
wyverns we know but if you like that
episode that one was great we feel like
this one has even stepped it up more so
go check that out that is on the channel
now boy did we hear about a wyverns
and I think I hear so much about Wow oh
my goodness no more wyverns Thank You
Danielle yes check that out and if you
are at La comic-con this weekend
there it is
Thank You JT for switching cameras in
the booth shadow GT so yeah if you are
at La comic-con this weekend also
Saturday 5:00 p.m. la comic-con
tournament of nerds it's a super fun
show where you get comedians debating on
behalf of pop culture characters just
it's like a roast battle but instead of
comedians getting personal you have a
roast battle of like Darth Vader vs Iron
Man okay and we're doing that tournament
of nerds 5 p.m. in room 403 B at comic
con la Comic Con and some of our many
friends law and Harris quois and ro
Danny Fernandez a lot of familiar pals
come check it out and yeah thank you
guys for making this an awesome epic
battle thank you for watching hoot hoot
hashtag owl nation hit me up on Twitter
at Hal Rudnick bye bye Thank You Billy
biz Ryan and JD
you